All right,
we've been talking about arguments that might give us reason to believe in the
existence of an immaterial soul.
The kinds of arguments we've been considering so far,
all for fall under the general rubric of inference to the best explanation we
posit,
or the fans of souls,
positive existence of souls.
So as to explain something that needs explaining about us.
Now the,
I've gone through a series of such arguments in the one that we ended with last
time was the suggestion that we need to believe in is this existence of a soul
in order to explain the fact that we've got free will.
The fact that we've got freewill is something that most of us take for granted
about ourselves.
But the complaint then,
or the objection to the physical list takes the form that we couldn't be a
merely physical entity because no merely physical entity could have freewill.
But we've got free will.
So there's gotta be something more to us than just being a physical object.
Now,
if we push the Dualis to explain what is it about freewill that rules out the
possibility that we are merely physical objects?
I think the natural suggestion does spell out the argument goes like this and
this is where we were at at the end of last time.
The thought is that there is a kind of in compatibility with being free and
being determined and after all from the physical,
physical,
his point of view,
we're just to kind of glorified robot able to do all sorts of things that the,
that most robots in most science fiction movies can do,
but still in a sense we're just to glorify physical object.
We're just,
we're just a robot and robots.
The objection goes our our program,
they necessarily follow their program more generally speaking we might say
they're subject to a deterministic laws.
The as physical objects.
It's true of them that they must do what the laws of physics and laws of nature
require that they do.
And and the laws of physics are ha take a deterministic form that the
determinism being a bit of philosophers jargon for,
for when it's true of these laws,
that or a physical or a system that if you set it up a certain way cause and
effect plays out such that given that initial set up,
the very same effect must follow.
It's determined by the laws of nature that the effect that follows will follow
from that cause.
And so if you rewind the tape and play it again over and over and over again,
each time you set things up the very same way,
they must move or transform or change or end up in the very same state.
Well that's what determinism is all about.
And intuitively it seems plausible to many people that you couldn't have
freewill and be subject to determinism because the notion of free will was that
even if I was in the very same spot again the very same situation again I could
have chosen differently so I wasn't determined or predetermined to make that
choice.
So if we were to spell out the argument somewhat more fully,
it might be we have free will but you can't both have freewill and be subject to
determinism or subject to deterministic laws and every physical object or every
purely physical object is subject to deterministic laws because the laws of
physics are deterministic.
You put these things together and you get the conclusion that we,
since we've got free will can't be a purely physical object.
There must be something more than the purely physical to us.
That's the argument I put up on the board the end of last class and here we've
got it up here.
Now one,
we have freewill to nothing.
Subject to determinism has freewill.
Three all purely physical systems are subject to determinism.
So conclusion,
we are not a purely physical system to explain the fact that we've got free
will.
So the objection goes,
we have to appeal to,
we have to posit the existence of a soul,
something nonphysical,
something more than purely physical.
Well that's the argument,
but I don't myself find the argument compelling.
Now the first thing to notice is that to get the conclusion we need all three
premises,
give up the conclusion that we've got to give up the premise that we've got free
will,
it won't follow that were nonphysical.
Even if something that did have free,
it would have to be nonphysical,
wouldn't follow that we are nonphysical.
That's true for each one of the premises.
Give it up.
The conclusion doesn't go through.
And the interesting thing is that each one of these premises could be plausibly
challenged.
Now as I said last time,
the subject of freewill or free will,
determinism,
causation,
responsibility.
This cluster of problems is an extremely difficult and complicated physical
problem and we could easily devote an entire semester to discussing it.
So all and so all we're doing here is the most quick and superficial glance.
But still,
let me quickly point out why you could resist the argument from freewill to the
existence of a soul.
First of all,
as I just noted,
the argument needs premise number one,
it's got to be the case to prove that we've got a soul,
at least for this argument,
to work to prove that we've got us all.
It's got to be the case that we've got freewill now that could be challenged.
There are philosophers who have said,
we certainly believe that we've got free will,
but it's an illusion.
We don't really have free will indeed.
Why don't have free well for precisely the reasons that appointed Dubai,
the rest of the argument,
they might say,
look,
well,
you know,
we're physical objects.
Determinism is true of us.
No physical object that's subject to determinism could have free will so we
don't have free will.
Of course,
we mistakenly believe we've got freewill.
We are physical objects that Labor under the illusion that we have freewill,
but after all,
freewill isn't something that you can just see,
right?
You can't peer into your mind and see the fact that you've got free will.
Yes,
we've got the sense that we could have acted differently,
but maybe that's an illusion.
As I say,
there are philosophers who argued that way,
have denied that we have free will and if we do conclude that we don't actually
have free will,
then we no longer have this argument for the existence of a soul.
It's a way to avoid the argument.
Although for what it's worth I should mention I don't myself believe that it's
false that we have free will.
That is to say I do think premise one is true.
I myself think we do have free will so although I don't like,
I don't believe the argument is sound.
Premise one doesn't happen to be the premise I myself would walk to reject.
Okay,
but there are other,
there are two other key premises.
What about premise number three?
All purely physical systems are subject to determinism.
While we need that premise as well to make the argument go,
suppose we think,
look,
you can't have free will and determinism.
You can't combine them.
The view of that you can't combine them is sometimes known as incompatible
wisdom for the obvious reason.
It's the view that these two things are incompatible.
You can't have determinism and free will.
Okay.
Suppose we do believe in determined incompatible wisdom and believe that we've
got freewill.
It would follow then that we're not subject to deterministic laws.
Well the Dualis says that shows us that we have to believe that there's
something nonphysical about us because after all premise three all purely
physical systems are subject to determinism isn't a true after all that the
basic laws of physics are deterministic laws
and the answer is well,
it's not so clear that it is true,
which is just to say that premise three of the argument can be rejected as well.
Now,
you know at this point I have to just confess as I've confessed at other times
before the the three is out is a claim about a empirical science.
What is our best theory about the laws of nature?
Tell us,
and I'm no scientist and I'm no specialist and sort of empirical matters and
believe I'm no authority on quantum mechanics,
our best theory of fundamental physics still I take it,
I gather.
Here's what I'm told,
that the standard interpretation of quantum mechanics says that despite what
money many of us might have otherwise believed,
the fundamental laws of physics are not in fact deterministic.
What does that mean?
Supposedly have got some sort of radioactive atom which has a certain chance of
decaying.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Well,
it means that you know,
there's maybe let's say an 80% chance that in the next 24 hours it will break
down.
Okay.
80% of atoms that are set up like that breakdown in the next 24 hours,
20% of them don't.
Now,
according to quantum mechanics on the standard interpretation,
that's all there is to say about it.
You have an Adam like that 80% chance in the next 24 hours,
it'll break down.
Suppose it does break down.
Can we say why it broke down?
Sure.
We can say,
well,
after all,
there was an 80% chance that it would take an Adam that after 24 hours hasn't
broken down,
can we say why hasn't broken down?
Sure.
There was a 20% chance that it wouldn't.
Can we explain why?
The ones that do breakdown breakdown and the ones that don't break down don't
break down.
No.
All we can say is there was an 80% chance it would 20% chance it wouldn't,
so most of them do.
Some of them don't.
That's as deep as the explanation goes.
There's nothing more.
Now,
you know when we've got our deterministic hats on,
we think to ourselves there's got to be some underlying causal explanation.
Some feature about the breakdown Adams that explained why they broke down.
That was missing from the non breakdown Adams.
That explained why they don't break down after all determinism.
Right.
If you set up the atoms exactly the same way,
they've always got a breakdown,
but the answer is according to the standard interpretation of quantum mechanics,
that's not how it works.
All there is to say is some of these are going to break down and some of these
won't.
The fundamental laws of physics according to the standard interpretation of
quantum mechanics are probabilistic determinism is not true.
Yeah.
At the level of fundamental physics.
Oh,
that's what I'm told.
Leave me.
I'm in no position to say,
but that's what I'm told.
And of course if that's true,
then premise three is false.
It just isn't true that all purely physical systems are subject determinism.
Yeah,
so even if it does turn out that you can't have free will and determinism,
that doesn't rule out the possibility that we are purely physical objects
because
okay,
not all purely physical systems are subject to determinism.
If determinism isn't true of us at the fundamental level.
Okay,
then even if you couldn't both have determinism and free will,
we could still have free will and yet for all that still be purely physical
systems.
Well,
I'm busy pointing out ways in which the argument doesn't succeed.
I also want to just take a moment and mentioned that premise two is also subject
to criticism.
Premise too though is that was the incompatiblist claim that nothing subject to
determinism has free will.
You can't combine them.
They're incompatible.
Now,
incompatible ism I take it is probably something like the common sense view
here.
So if you have that,
probably most of you believe,
but again,
it's worth noting that philosophically it can be challenged.
There are philosophers,
and here I'll tip my hat and say I'm one of them.
There are philosophers who believe that in fact,
the idea of freewill is not incompatible ism with incompatible with determinism.
So even if determinism work true of us,
that wouldn't rule out our having freewill because you can appearances to the
contrary,
not withstanding,
have both determinism and free will.
They're compatible,
hence this views known as compatible wisdom.
If we accept compatible ISM will be able to say,
look,
maybe we have free will and determinism is true of us.
But for all of that we're still just purely physical systems.
Okay.
Even if quantum mechanics was wrong and somehow,
you know,
at the macro level it all the in determinism,
nope,
come boils out,
whatever.
And at the macro level,
we are deterministic systems.
So what if a deterministic system could nonetheless have freewill?
We could still be purely physical systems.
Now mind you,
I haven't said anything today to convince you of the truth of compatiblist them.
Nor am I going to try to do that.
Okay.
My point here was only to say we shouldn't be so quick to think that we have to
believe in the existence of a soul in order to explain our having free will.
It takes all of the premises of the argument to get the conclusion that the soul
exists and each one of the premises can be challenged
and here,
I mean not merely,
well,
logically speaking,
you know,
of course you can reject and print any premise of any argument.
No,
I mean there are reasonable philosophical or scientific grounds for worrying
about each one of the premises.
The argument requires a lot that doesn't prove that the argument fails,
but it does mean that you're going to have your work cut out for you if you're
going to use this route to arguing for the existence of a soul.
All right,
let's,
let's recap.
As I said,
we've been considering different kinds of arguments for the existence of a soul,
each of which appeals to some feature about us,
our creativity,
our ability to feel,
the fact that we have a qualitative aspect of experience.
Our ability to reason what have you.
Some fact about us that calls out for explanation and the claim on the part of
the dual list was we couldn't explain it without appealing to a soul and I've
argued,
I've,
I've shared with you my reasons for thinking that those arguments are not
compelling,
but notice that all of the kinds of considerations I pointed to so far are what
we might think of as every day familiar features about us.
It's an everyday occurrence that we can think and reason and feel and be
creative or choose otherwise and have freewill maybe the better arguments where
the sole focus not on the everyday but on the unusual on the supernatural here
we might then have an entire other family of arguments,
set of arguments.
Again,
still have the form inference to the best explanation.
Maybe we need to posit the soul in order to explain ghosts.
Maybe we need deposit the soul in order to explain ESP.
Maybe we need to posit the soul in order to explain near death experiences.
Maybe we need to posit the soul in order to explain what goes on and say on says
or communications from the dead or what have you.
For any one of those,
we could again run an argument where he say,
look,
here's something that needs explaining the best explanation appeals to the soul.
Now I'm going to be rather quicker in discussing this family of arguments about,
let me take at least a couple of minutes and do something about that.
Take for example,
near death experiences.
This is something that you read a bit about in the selection foam Shichen Vaughn
in your course packet.
The basic idea is probably familiar to most of you anyway,
that the following thing happens with people who,
you know,
maybe their heart goes into a cardiac arrest,
what have you,
they they die on the operating table,
but then they're brought back to life as we,
as we put it,
and many such people when we questioned them afterwards,
have a very striking experience and one of the things that's striking is how
similar the experience is from person to person and from culture to culture.
That they've got some notion as they were dead on the operating table of leaving
their body.
Perhaps they begin to view their body from up floating up above,
above it.
Then she will leave.
Perhaps they leave the operating room altogether in this,
in this experience that they're having and they have a feeling of joy and
euphoria.
They have some experience of going through a tunnel,
seeing some light at the end of the tunnel,
perhaps at the other end of the tunnel,
they begin to have some communications or see some loved one who's died
previously or perhaps some famous religious person in their,
in their true teachings of their tradition,
their religious tradition.
They have the sense that what they done is basically died and gone to heaven,
but then suddenly they get yanked back and they wake up in the hospital room so
they've had near death experiences or perhaps a better word to put it would be
they've had death experiences but then had been brought back to life now,
no,
there it is right in your survey people and people have these experiences and
now we have to ask ourselves what explains this and here's a perfectly straight
forward and natural explanation.
These people died,
there are bodies died and they went to the next world.
They went to the next life they went to heaven but then were yanked back.
Now their bodies were lying there on the operating table.
They're bodies weren't in heaven,
so something non bodily went to heaven.
That's how the explanation goes.
It's a natural,
straightforward explanation of what's gone on here.
Hence inference to the best explanation.
We need to posit the soul,
something in material that survives the death of the body that can leave the
body go up to heaven.
Though as it happens in these cases,
you know the,
the ties never completely broken.
They get yanked back,
the soul gets yanked back by whatever cause and reconnected to the body.
It's as though we might think of there being two rooms.
He was a kind of analogy here.
There's the room that this world represents,
this life represents and what happens in these experiences is that your soul
leaves this room and goes into a second room,
the room of the next world or the next life,
but for various reasons isn't allowed to stay in the next room.
It gets yanked back to this room.
Well that's a possible explanation.
And in a moment I'll ask whether it's the best possible explanation,
but before we do turn to that question there an objection to this entire way of
looking at things that's probably worth pausing for a moment and considering the
objection is similar to the kind of dismissive attitude that we saw at the
beginning of the course about the question,
you know,
could I survive my death?
Well dog,
could there be life after there's no more life?
Well,
of course not.
Here in the objection says this two room notions gotta be mistaken.
It can't be that what's going on in near death experiences is that people are
reporting about what it's like to be dead because so the objection says they
never really died after all.
No 20 minutes later,
whatever it is,
there they are up and about,
well not up and about the presumably line in their hospital beds,
but they're clearly alive,
hence at files that they never really died.
Or if you want,
you could say maybe they died,
but since they obviously didn't die permanently after all,
we were brought back to life.
How can they possibly tell us what it's like to be permanently dead?
How can we take their experiences as vertical reports of the afterlife?
Because what we want to know is what does it like to be permanently dead and
these people were never permanently dead.
So whatever unusual experiences they may be having,
they are not reports of the afterlife.
That's how the objection goes.
Although I think it was pausing for a moment to raise that objection.
It's not an objection that I think we should take all that seriously.
I suppose we were to agree.
All right.
Strictly speaking,
these people didn't die or strictly speaking,
they didn't die,
certainly at least permanently does it follow from that that their experiences
should not be taken as evidence of what the afterlife is like?
I think that's really a,
a misguided objection smell.
Somebody said,
look,
I spent 20 years living in France and then I came back to the United States.
And so I want to tell you what it's like in France.
And somebody says,
you know,
you never really moved to France permanently,
so your experiences in France,
whatever they are interesting as they may be,
can't really cast any light on what it would be like to permanently move to
France.
We'd say,
yeah,
give me a break.
Right.
It's true that of course I didn't move to France permanent lease still.
No,
I have some experience of France and so I can,
you know,
a great deal after all 20 years,
I can give you a pretty good idea of what it's like to live in France,
even if I didn't move there for the rest of my life without ever coming back.
Keck say quite as much.
If you've only been in France for a couple of days before,
I'll coming back.
But still you can say something relevant.
Indeed.
Suppose I never went into France at all.
Suppose all that happened was I stood right on the border.
Okay.
And peered into France.
Talk to some people in France.
They were on the French side of the border.
I was on the other side,
but I talked to them for a while.
Still,
I never went in,
but for all that I might have something helpful to say about what it's like in
France.
Okay,
well that's the right thing to say about the France case.
Then why not say the same thing about the near death near death experience case.
Even if these people didn't stay in the second room,
they didn't stay dead.
They had some experience of being dead.
Isn't that relevant to what it would be like to be dead?
Or even if we say no,
strictly speaking,
these people didn't die at all.
They were just on the border looking in.
They never strictly speaking died at all.
So what they were on the border looking in to suggested that couldn't be
relevant.
Evidence is like saying,
I can't tell you anything interesting about what's going on in the hallway right
there now because after all,
I'm not in the hallway.
I'm hearing the lecture hall,
but so what,
even though I'm hearing the lecture hall,
I can see into the hallway and tell you what's going on in it.
So attempts to dismiss the appeal to near death experiences on what we might
call philosophical grounds.
This would be the bad notion of philosophy.
I'm philosophical grounds.
I think that's gotta be misguided still.
That doesn't mean that we should believe the argument for the existence of the
soul from near death experiences because the question remains what's the best
explanation of what's going on in near death experiences.
Now,
one possibility as I suggested was you know what I call a second ago that the
two room explanation,
there's the room of this life and there's the room of the next life and people
who have near death experiences either temporarily we're in the second room or
else at least they were glancing into the second room.
That's one possible explanation.
But of course there's a different possible explanation.
The one room explanation.
There's just life,
this life and as you come very close to the wall of the room,
things end up looking and seeming and feeling rather different
then they do in the middle of the room.
Now
maybe the one room metaphor is not the best metaphor because it immediately
prompts the question,
well,
what's on the other side of the wall?
Okay.
And of course the physical,
his suggestion is there isn't anything on the other side of the wall.
So maybe a better way would talk about it would just be life's a biological
process.
We're all familiar with that process,
sort of in its middle stretches
and it's closing stretches.
Some fairly unusual biological processes kick in.
Okay.
In rare but not unheard of cases.
Some people begin to have those unusual biological processes and then return to
the normal biological processes and can talk about what was happening in the
unusual biological processes,
which is just to say we need to offer a biological slash physical explanation of
what goes on in near death experiences.
Now mind you,
that's not yet to offer the physical explanation.
It's just a promissory note.
We now have two rival explanations,
the sole dualist explanation that we went into the other world and the physical
list,
promissory note that we can explain the white lights and the feeling of euphoria
and the D and C in your body from a distance in physical terms.
Yeah.
We don't really have very much of a physical explanation until we begin to offer
scientific accounts of each of those aspects of near death experience.
But this is in fact an area on which scientists work.
And you saw some of the beginnings of an explanation offered in the reading by
Shichen Vaughn.
So for example,
when the body's in stress as would likely happened towards the end of the
biological processes,
when the body's in stress,
certain endorphins get released by the body,
perhaps that explains the feelings of euphoria.
Okay.
When the body's in stress,
we have various unusual stimulations of the visual sections of the brain and
perhaps that explains the,
the white light or the feeling of compression and the tunnel.
Now.
Again,
I'm not any kind of scientist and so I'm not in any position to say,
look,
here's the details of the explanation,
but you get the beginnings of that sketched in the readings.
No,
it's a judgment call you've got to make.
Does it seem more plausible that we can explain these experiences in terms of
the traumatic stress that your body and brain is going through,
your brain is going through when you,
you know,
are near dying
towards it?
More plausible to suggest no.
What's happened here is a soul has been released from connection with the body
for mine money.
I find the beginnings of the scientific explanation sufficiently persuasive and
sufficiently compelling that I don't find the argument from near death
experience as an argument for the existence of a soul.
I don't find it a specialty persuasive.
Of course,
there are various other things we could appeal to in terms of supernatural
occurrences.
Right.
I've only mentioned,
only discussed now in detail one of them,
but there's a variety of things about people who can communicate from the dead
or ghosts or say answers or what have you and what the physical list would need
to do for each one of those.
You know,
for each one of those you can imagine a dual list who says we need to believe in
a soul.
So as to explain seances,
how do we explain the fact that the person who's conducting the seance knows
things about you know,
your history,
that only your dead uncle would know.
The dual is can explain that by appealing to ghosts and the like.
How does the physical list explain things like that?
Short answer is,
I don't know.
I'm not the kind of person who makes it his business to try to explain away
those things in physicalist,
naturalistic,
materialistic,
scientific terms.
But there are people who make it their business.
So for example,
there's a magician.
The question it's not,
could I explain to you how the seance managers to do the amazing things that it
does?
You're wasting your time asking somebody like me.
The person to ask is,
is a magician,
somebody who's profession it is to fool people and they could look like they can
do things with magic.
So in fact,
there are professional magicians who make it their business to debunk people who
claim to genuinely be in contact with the dead and the like.
There's a magician,
I think his name is the amazing Randy who has a sort of standing offer.
He says,
you know,
you show me what happened in the seance or in communication with the dead,
what have you,
and I'll show you how to do.
I'll debunk it for you.
Spoiler alert.
Right?
And there's a standing offer.
He says,
you know,
I'll pay whatever the amount is,
$10,000 10 the first person who can document some effect,
dawn in supernatural terms that I can't reproduce through trickery so far,
he's never had to pay out.
Oh,
again,
that doesn't prove that the dual list is wrong.
It could be that there are genuine say answers.
It could be if there really are ghosts,
it could be that there really is communication from the dead
as is typically the case.
You've got to decide for yourself what strikes you as the better explanation.
Okay.
Is the supernatural dualist explanation the more likely one or is the physical
list explanation?
The more likely one.
What
you haven't dream where your dead mother has come back to talk to you.
One possible explanation to dual list.
That's the ghost of your mother in material soul that she is communicating to
you while you're asleep.
Second possible explanation.
It's just a dream.
Of course you dream about your mother because your unconscious cares about her.
What's the better explanation?
We don't have the time here to go case by case by case and ask ourselves how
does the evidence fall down one side versus the other.
But when I review the evidence,
I come away thinking there is no good reason to move beyond the physical.
So again,
let's recap.
One group of arguments for the existence of a soul says we need to posit a soul
in order to explain something,
whether it's something every day or something supernatural.
Okay.
The existence of a soul would be the beginnings of a possible explanation.
Yeah,
but the question is never is that a possible explanation,
but is it the best explanation
and when I review these various arguments,
I come away thinking the better explanation falls with the physical list.
Mind you.
Yeah.
I don't want to deny that there are some things the physicalist has not yet done
a very compelling job of explaining in,
as I've mentioned previously,
I think there are mysteries and puzzles about the nature of consciousness,
the qualitative aspect of experience,
what it's like to smell coffee or taste pineapple or see red.
It's very hard to see how you explained that in physical,
his terms.
So to that extent,
I think we can say the jury may still be out.
Yeah.
But I don't think what we should say is the better explanation lies with the
dual list because I think positive in his soul doesn't really yet offer us the
explanation.
It just holds out the promise of an explanation.
So at best that's a tie and hence no compelling reason to accept the existence
of a soul.
It would be one thing if we could see that no conceivable physicalist
explanation could possibly work,
but I don't think we're in that situation.
Yeah.
All we're in right now is perhaps an existence up with a guard to consciousness.
Maybe some other things we don't yet see how to explain it,
but not yet seen.
How to explain it is not the same thing as seeing that it can't be explained on
physicalist terms.
Of course,
again,
if we had a dualist explanation with some details really worked out
okay,
maybe we'd have to say,
look,
this is the better explanation,
but dualism doesn't so much offer the explanation.
Typically as just say,
well,
maybe we'd be better off positing something immaterial
that I think is not a very compelling argument.
Okay.
Well let's ask what other kinds of arguments could be offered for the existence
of a soul?
I want to emphasize the point that the various arguments I've been talking about
so far,
although they have this common strand inference to the best explanation are each
separate and distinct arguments.
One of them might work even though the other ones don't work,
but I want to turn now to a rather different kind of argument.
The argument I'm about to sketch is a purely philosophical argument.
Not really so much a matter of who can explain this or that feature of us better
than anybody else.
It's an argument that doesn't seem to have any empirical premises works from
purely armchair philosophical reflection and the striking thing is that many
people find this a pretty compelling argument.
The argument,
I'm going to give traces back to Descartes,
the great early modern philosopher,
well not going to follow the details,
it was talking about be the basic idea.
It goes back to Descartes and it starts by asking you to imagine a story.
So I'm going to tell the story in the first person I'm not tell about myself,
but you'll sort of,
you'll find the argument sort of perhaps more persuasive if,
as I tell the story,
you imagine the story being told about you.
So each one of you should translate this into a story about yourself.
You know,
your morning.
So this is a story about my morning.
Imagine this isn't of course actually happen.
But imagine the crucial point here is simply that we can imagine this story
happening.
Okay?
Not even that we think it's so impuricably possible.
Just it's,
it's conceivable.
It's an imaginable story.
All right,
so suppose that I woke up this morning.
That is just say at a certain point,
I look around my room and I see the familiar sights of my dark and bedroom.
Okay.
I hear it.
Perhaps the sounds of the cars outside my house,
my alarm clock ringing,
what have you.
I move out of the room toward the bathroom,
planning to brush my teeth as I enter the bathroom.
It's much more light.
I look in the mirror and here's where things get really weird.
I don't see anything.
Normally.
Of course when I look in the mirror,
I see my face,
I see my head,
I see the reflection of my torso,
but now as I'm looking into the mirror,
I don't see anything at all.
Instead,
I see the shower reflected behind me.
Normally that's blocked of course by me,
by my body,
but I don't see my body slightly freaked out.
I reach for my head,
or perhaps we should say I reached for where I would expect my head to be,
but I don't feel anything there.
Okay.
Glancing down at my arms,
I don't see any arms.
Now I'm really panicking.
As I began trying to touch my body,
I don't feel anything.
I don't,
not only can I feel,
I think with my fingers,
I don't have any sensations where my body should be.
Now we could continue this story,
but I probably said enough for you to grant that what I've just started doing,
a novelist could do a better job of telling the story than I just did.
But what I've just done was basically,
imagine I've imagined a story in which I discovered that my body doesn't exist,
or I've imagined a story in which my body's perhaps ceased to exist or I've
imagined a story in which I exist,
or at least my mind exists.
You know,
I'm,
I'm thinking thoughts like,
why can't I see my body in the mirror?
Why can't I feel my head?
What's going on?
I'm panicking,
right?
We've got a story in which I'm thinking all sorts of thoughts.
My mind clearly exists and yet for all that my body does not exist.
We,
we can certainly it Siemens.
Imagine that possibility.
Now the brilliant thing about this argument is it goes from that to a conclusion
about there being a difference between my mind and my body.
What we've just done after all is imagine that my mind exists,
but my body does not.
And what does that show day cart says what it shows is the mind and the body
must be to logically distinct things.
Yeah,
the mind and the body cannot be the same thing.
Because after all,
what I just did was imagine my mind existing with out my body.
But how could I even do that?
Even in imagination?
How could it even be possible to imagine my mind without my body if talking
about my mind is just a way of talking about my body.
If they're really bottom line,
metaphysically speaking,
the same thing,
then you couldn't have one without the other.
I mean after all so,
so,
so here's a podium,
try to tell a story in which this podium exists,
but this podium does not exist.
You can't do it right.
If the podium is just one thing,
the podium,
and if there's just one thing you could tell a story in which it exists,
you could tell a story in which it doesn't exist,
but you can't tell a story in which it exists and doesn't exist.
If I can tell a story in which a exists and B doesn't exist,
it's got to follow that.
A and B are not the same thing because if B was just another word for another
way of talking about a than to imagine a existing but be not existing would be
imagining a existing but well B is just a not existing,
but of course you can't imagine a world in which a exists but a doesn't exist.
Yeah,
put the same point the other way around.
If I can imagine a without B,
then a m B have to be logically distinct things.
They cannot be identical.
Okay.
But since I can imagine my mind existing without my body,
it follows that my mind and my body have to be logically distinct things.
They cannot be identical.
My mind cannot just be a way of talking.
Talking about my mind cannot just be a way of talking about my body
now.
It's very cool.
Argh.
You know,
philosophers love this argument and I've got to tell you to this day,
there's a debate in the philosophical community about whether or not this
argument works.
It's one thing to be clear,
a couple of things to be clear about.
What exactly is this argument not doing?
The argument is not sane.
If something is possible,
if I can imagine it.
It's true.
Yeah.
I can imagine unicorns.
That doesn't mean unicorns exist.
That's not what the argument is saying.
The argument is only making a much more specific claim.
If I can imagine one thing without the other,
they must be separate things.
Now,
of course,
it could still be that in the real world,
the one thing cannot exist without the other.
There may be some sort of metaphysical laws that tie the two things so tightly
together that you will never actually get one without the other.
That's not the question.
The point is just if I can at least imagine the one thing without the other,
they must in fact be two separate things because if it was really just one thing
there,
you couldn't imagine it without it.
Since I can imagine my mind without my body,
it must be the case that my mind is something separate and distinct from my
body.
Otherwise,
how could I imagine it existing without the body if they were the same thing,
I couldn't.
I can't imagine the body existing without the body.
If the mind is just a way of talking about the body,
how could I imagine the mind without the body,
since I can imagine the mind without the body,
it follows that they're separate.
So the mind is not the body.
After all,
it's something different.
It's the soul.
Is that a good argument or not?
That's where we'll start next time.